okay well for those joining the
livestream this is one of our infinite
series of meetings about new features in
Wolfram language we've got a number of
items today the first I think is very
straightforward string take drop okay so
we have take a drop which just says sum
just breaks a string so like for for
example we'll do that right mm-hmm
seems like string take drop is a
obviously useful thing if one's
iterating through a string by the way
we're hearing a bunch of background
noise sounds like it might be an echo or
something um so did you return a list of
two strings I think so I mean just
exactly analogous to take job
somebody needs to adjust the audio stuff
um okay okay okay that was really simple
okay let's move on to the next item that
is much meteor I think right so we have
been implementing a few improvements and
changes in data object recently but we
haven't done the parallel thing in
object-- we so the discussion is for
deposit okay so let me just understand I
mean so if I want to for example go
let's imagine I'm doing a data object of
now and a granularity of day okay that's
nice and let's say I do a granularity of
millisecond or something I just don't
have that no other thing we have this
one
okay so instant is that and do we have
second yes yes we do okay okay um
okay what is the ultimate purpose of
time object well for example yes it
could be a generic time within a 24-hour
period so so is it the case if I want to
do a generic April 18th how do I do it
we don't have a language level version
of recurring dates or date patterns like
that it's one of the general topics
we're looking at discussing for dates
but there's some there's been some
back-and-forth and trying to figure out
you know what the ultimate purpose of it
is because you know the primary use is
we have recurring dates are in
scheduling so things like cron jobs or
in indicating things like holidays which
are kind of a special version of of
scheduling or doing some sort of
patterned extraction say I want every
fourth Tuesday in the month from this
time series to do some aggregation for
and the the way that we want to
generalize that means that we can't you
know we've looked at the idea of having
you know data object of you know the
year parameter being none or right right
and the problem generally is is that
that's kind of a restrictive design in
terms of having general dates we can use
it if we basically want to have
something like April 4th but we can't
necessarily say every Tuesday with that
notation or every fourth Tuesday okay so
you know when we invented granularity
that was a thing like this so the issue
is you want to be able to have
essentially a date pattern that
represents any date of a certain now
some things aren't date patterns so for
example 2018 isn't a date pattern it's
completely anchored right what one could
conceivably look at it is it look at it
as a pattern where you say the pattern
is this is the year and any time within
that I think that's more Garrety I mean
the pattern would be it's you know
imagine there was another you know
Common Era so to speak this would be the
you know the year 2018 with respect to
you know it could be a different
calendar system or something like that
it's something that we don't you know
different calendar systems are one thing
but it's it's a that's a different thing
I mean it's like you know if
civilization restarted a hundred
thousand years from now and there was
another 2018 then that will be what
that's about and that's not what we are
you know that's not what we're building
a product for if we go back to the April
you know it could be the case we want to
say any April mm-hmm right we might want
to say any eighteenth of the month we
certainly might want to say any first of
the month
great um and any Wednesday and so on so
I mean there's there's the notion of
well there's the notion of any and every
which might be different notions so if
we say any any April I don't I think
this is a useful construct I mean so the
question is what kind of a thing is that
construct so if I take a look at that
for example um okay so this is a date
object there's its main payload there's
its granularity there's its calendar
type and there's this time zone yes okay
so the question is what could this look
like what would the thing look like that
is the any April right so roughly any
April is you know we could say you know
any April is sort of that I mean it's as
you said it's a different thing to say
that there's an arbitrary pattern I mean
there's two different things there's one
thing which is the structural pattern
which is any April so to speak another
thing is this whole elaborate collection
of possible you know of alternatives
basically that says it's a date that
matches the that is in the following
sequence if I'm making sense so yeah
these dates which a structural patterns
seem to me different untreatable in a
different way than the arbitrary you
know collection of time points so if you
it might be relevant to the discussion
here there's a future eyes draft page
called date select where I was trying to
sort of generalize the idea of using
named elements okay for you know again
changing the idea from this structural
approach to being potentially a element
based so using the same elements we have
in date value where we could say you
know this in particular is you know
here's a bunch of dates I want all the
ones that match this particular criteria
but we're you know in this case the
basic implementation uses named slots
that refer to date value elements and
how on earth would you pick those up so
in other words you turn the date so
that's actually I think then we don't
have which is to turn a date into an
association which says year arrow blah
mmm
you know month arrow blah I mean I could
imagine having some alternative form of
a date object in which that's how it
works
yes I'm sort of like can we've looked at
the idea of having you know that as a
flexible constructor input or I'm not
sure about having that is an internal
representation that seems useful if we
say date object of year month whatever
as an association that seems like
something that could be useful the
problem is that date value has a lot of
extra stuff in it that isn't you know
it's not literally you don't want to
literally generate it for an association
right so how are you handling that in
your date select concept so the the toy
implementation of it would basic you
know basically did date value extraction
for the parameter you named so if you
said yeah I know so for a lot of them
they're not like super important
elements of the you know whether it has
an ampm in it or not is not particularly
really useful you can look and say is
the hour greater than blah but why is
that equal to Monday the symbol because
we Ford a name which is the the function
that returns the day of the week it
returns a symbol so de name is a ISM a
so if I do the name of today if I say
date value of let's say now and then I
say day name I'm gonna get back a symbol
yeah the default is a symbol date value
can specify if you want it as a string
or something else but where do you
specify that when I is a third argument
okay yes in some of these you may want a
string or a real value or a quantity
some of them you know there isn't a
quantity of day name so it will complain
I see but so so how would you handle
that I mean this is sort of an
interesting construct here I mean that
you want to be able to say I mean but
then there's the the other thing which
is select from the continuous sequence
of time mm-hmm I mean we have this date
range concept right right his name is
evaluation it's the same as range yeah
it's evaluated right as opposed to
something which represents the date
interval which we don't have yet is that
correct that's correct we don't have it
there there third example in that ref
page has a prototype notation for you
know there's a date interval so the
example of that one yeah so selective
date interval of give a start an
endpoint and say I want all of the days
within this that are a month of August
yes okay okay okay so I mean in a sense
you've got what I'm talking about here
is a date cases that works with the date
pattern right
the motivation for this extended
language was that the t-state cases
cannot handle weeks for example I
understand with a structural pattern you
can't handle weeks okay but so is there
a role for a so so what you're imagining
then these are all literal outputs they
do not represent they're not solving the
problem of representing any April or any
Monday right that's very distracting
particular you know Mondays or whatever
yeah I is far the couple of times I'd
look at it I haven't found a clean way
to represent a generic or a recurring
date where you know we can we can
specify this sort of element-wise
criteria or cases like pattern okay why
isn't it something like a pure I don't
think this is the right name but a date
what will be the right name I mean this
is so let's imagine that we said you
know day name equals equals Monday let's
imagine that we had an object like that
that represents any Monday he says I
don't think it needs to even have the
day name equals I mean it's just like
like I mean it's sort of an any date
this isn't quite right so let me suggest
a possibility that we have been
discussing some times which is that the
actual elements of the list we put in
the first argument of the data object
depend on the on the calendar we use so
we had a calendar in which the list
contains weeks then which because it's
for example year comma week Akuma they
our Exeter then we could hundred weeks
what aspect of weeks I mean the numbered
week in the year but it might be
inconsistent yeah well so the the Orca
typical calendar this is their the ISO
8601 standard has a year week calendar
where the first element is the year
number the second one is the week within
the year and the third one is the day
within the week and they have a specific
criteria for determining this is the
first week of the year and if they're 52
or 53 weeks within year and how that
gets handled fine well if the you know
if history have been different than the
Babylonians had an emetic months or
whatever then we might be working with
Isis or whatever but as it is you know
sort of all over calling history we've
had ended up with months and so on yeah
and it doesn't it doesn't generalize to
other calendars and so there's right so
I don't think that's really good so the
issue is let's imagine we had a
construct that means any Monday or every
Monday and I think those two concepts
are a little different every versus any
okay so then what we might want to do is
say you know date cases sort of within
the state interval law dubois what are
the things that match that you know the
any Monday thing mm-hmm
another thing we might want to do yeah I
mean this is sort of a resolution of
that pattern object an explicit
resolution of that pattern object much
as here I mean that's equivalent for
this isn't it because in in my theory
what we're crit is that same type of
thing it's precisely equivalent to date
select of the data interval with a
criterion yeah so what are the other use
cases all right
so the the other two prominent ones
besides strict selection are time series
sampling or resampling and notation for
scheduling slash holidays okay well
let's look at time series sampling okay
so let's say I want to pick out you know
what was the temperature every Monday
okay so let's imagine that let's get a
time series okay so let's say by the way
I don't even know how to UM where it's
gonna think here is but who cares what
happens if I just say here quantity
three weeks does that work I am not sure
what it would do it would mean the last
three weeks I think that's something we
should make work we've generally tried
not to mix too much the the notion of
duration quantities and dates up you
know you can know I know this is this is
kind of a painful construct I mean it's
explicit but it's kind of a painful
construct and everybody kind of knows
what you mean if you say a temperature
data for three weeks
III think yeah things where the second
argument is a time spec which is the
case for this for financial data and for
a few other things I think we should
support the idea where if that's just a
quantity
it's basically equivalent to now minus
the quantity two now why don't you
suggest that - I guess it's Michael who
deals with this yeah I can I can mention
that okay so we've got a time series
here and what you're saying is let's
imagine that we just want to get the
values so let's imagine from that time
series that we want to get the value at
6:00 a.m. every day okay so what would
be our method for doing that right now
so we have with the I'm not sure offhand
with the the best way to do that I go
sure would probably be better able to
answer than me but I don't think we have
a great way to do this yeah I remember
Jose do you remember we had discussed
briefly with Gosha about the way she was
using the holiday calendars to try and
sort of create that artificial selection
do you remember what the specific
application was no I don't so we see if
we can get gauche of Jones meeting all
right okay okay so does that work okay
to let's say one week ago that
definitely isn't gonna work um so one
week ago okay so this will resample we
got an echo again by the way okay so
that will give us a smaller time series
we got an echo again somehow um that
gives us a smaller time series but if
what I want to get out of here is the
temperature at 6:00 a.m. every day how
do I do it
okay so that's that's one issue and in a
sense what I would want is to be able to
say given a time series and given a list
of times
you know time one time to etcetera
etcetera etcetera I want to be able to
apply the time series to that list of
times and I think I can do some of that
right if I take that time series I say
this time series here line 30 and I say
let's say 18 hours ago
you
that was not encouraging at all
but worked
people understand what that's supposed
to do here
and it's weird that it's got the failed
head well the whole thing is weird but
you know it's it's not trivial because
it has to do interpolation and if
there's missing data it's got to deal
with that right ok well let's wait for
go sure - oh yeah ok hi um you're a
little hard to hear if you can speak up
somehow be good oh okay alright you see
my screen yes I can see your screen I'm
trying to see what's going on okay so I
got a time series of temperature data
last three weeks from here and I thought
I could just put in a time as a sub
value there I did that and it went
bonkers
so is that correct what I what I'm
trying to do there right I mean I should
be able to do that for a time series
right yeah that's very weird by the way
I don't think this is but could we
please fix this this documentation to
use something not as ancient as this
okay okay so this is certainly showing
the exact same thing so why isn't this
working
so if I say mean a percent thirty oh is
that the problem what happens if I say I
mean that's wrong in its own right but
if I say delete missing from percent
thirty what's it gonna do right now what
the the thing that we can do right now
is to when you create time series you
can input you know the missing data
method as automatic and it for a time
series it would just interpolate you
know have a linear interpolation in
place of the missing that's what we do
what we can do right now and the mean
result right it's also correct because
there were there missing you know
objects in the values so that's what
by the way this should probably do
something reasonable that's in the works
it's it's working towards that okay yes
later method day tomatoes that no other
completion that is a bug there should be
Auto completion for that right yes okay
so now if I do that yeah
and now if I try mean of that it works
just fine if I say percent thirty eight
to sub you know eighteen hours ago let's
say I'll have to figure out what's going
on here because it's that's bug I think
you might percent thirty eight nine
percent thirty well well that would help
that worked okay so that problem has to
do with the treatment of missing I mean
what do you think it should do away from
the missing data it should just work
well so normally if if it's between the
timestamps that would interpolate if
it's outside it would extrapolate and if
it falls on a timestamp it should just
give you the whatever the value is so
the fact that it shows failed it it just
indicates that there is something you
know it's a bug of some case what I'm
saying is right so the interpolation if
it's linear interpolation it doesn't if
you're away from the place where it's
missing it's all going to be fine
yes um okay all right so that's somebody
on our live stream is saying should
distinguish between date intervals like
three weeks an absolute data intervals
like dates between now and now
absolutely that that's exactly what
we're doing here the
okay so what we're talking about is if I
want to get all right so so the way to
select so if I wanted to get the
temperature at 6 a.m. every day right
what you're telling me is if I went to
line 38 I could say date range let's
let's walk through how this would
actually work
okay so right now be now - three weeks
but how do I get 6 a.m. each day
somebody how would I get the how would I
get the date range which is the 6 a.m.
of each of those days so generating
specifically at 6 a.m. we don't have
like a great function for it you could
do like a current date plus 6 hours yeah
I mean we don't have like a date coerce
function to basically say take this date
and turn it into the appropriate so what
this is is instead of the granularity
where you say given a particular time so
granularity means given this instant in
time get the enclosing step second week
whatever it is right you know there's a
different thing which is given this
granularity get the one or more
instances of this thing within that
granularity so it's kind of like date
select isn't it yeah I mean in other
words if this said date select of let's
say I mean it could just be today comma
and then it could be um what is the what
is the right term for date value
let's say our well our equals six right
so what that should return is a list
that corresponds to those times you know
that should give you a list of things
and that this seems not completely silly
so if dates select is given a certain
granularity there's an implicit
regularity is it returning because what
you might think is you know in other
words so that this state select thing
has so date range goes from start to
stop and with a certain step and what
granularity does it return so the the
general paradigm has been maintained the
granularity of the starting object so if
you put in days it will try and return
in days but we try and have it operate
in you know if I say I want to run from
today till tomorrow in steps of a minute
getting back a bunch of repeated things
that are all the same days are very
useful so and so let me just look at the
inverse thing so if I say let's see if I
want to get the sunrise so let's say I
say date range you know today - you know
one month okay - today and that will now
do it in steps of days right yep and if
I now say sunrise of that
it's gonna give me that event series and
now if I say date value of that comet
hour oh come on why didn't that work I
mean deep value is primarily designed as
an extraction function I know but but
let's so let's go to normal or percent
for these dates maybe okay so there I've
got my know that's complete nonsense
where how do I get out the dates here
that sunrise thing how do we get the the
individual dates so I could say values
of that time series right right okay
great
so that's sunrise at those times so now
I say date value of that what the heck
oh I see what I want I want how do I get
the fractional day
so there's day a fraction or day exact
will give I don't need to be percent
forty okay so that lets say if I say
dandy weird huh I wonder that must be
what the heck is that Wiggles there who
knows yeah I mean the the resolution for
Sun rises in minute steps so there may
be actually look there's repeated
elements may just kind of be the
resolution where we're hang out yeah
okay
all right okay but so the question now
is if I wanted to get again let's go
back to my time series okay if I want to
extract um
let's see if I want to extract the thing
let's let's return to what we were
saying before so we could imagine a date
select that gives us a list of specific
dates I have a certain granularity I
don't know what the granularity is that
match a particular criterion here right
well this could be a date interval but
doesn't need to be a date interval it
could just be um it could just say date
select and we could have a simplified
syntax of year for example which would
mean the current year yeah each granular
date has an implicit exact range today
is from the first moment of today until
the last moment this year is January 1st
through December 31st right and someone
on the live stream is asking about date
deltas vs. yeah let me show you how it
works I mean if I take two dates yeah I
can just go ahead and subtract them and
I will get a a date Delta um and I think
all this just works and I think date
interval what's that yeah our date
Delta's our quantity is their durations
of time right which is I think exactly
as you would want them now
okay so let's go back to this this dates
are like we've again got this weird
background noise um we could debug that
um it's a stream
uh okay um
okay so let's
go back
uhh
all right where were we so we're talking
about something a funk piece of
functionality we don't have now which is
how to get
now presumably by the way these
both date value
dates select should work on time series
and should select those pieces of the
time series what does is there a there
is a time series selectors they're not
no there is not there is not okay um
alright okay so does this seem like a
reasonable function I mean this is what
you were proposing here over here right
and as this is this compatible with what
you were proposing you're saying there's
a list here I'm saying just have a date
interval or a granular date object yeah
I think both of those certainly work in
the same way the main the main
difference there in terms of the
criteria is do we want to have it be
strings or named hashes and oh yeah this
is wrong this is crazy
what I've written there is absolutely
crazy yeah and so I think you know the
the current designer had there had a
third argument which is you know the
first end cases we may also want to have
either an option or argument to handle
granularity we can do an automatic one
and say if you're looking at today in
your specification as ours they should
probably be our granular steps but maybe
you say I want the hours but I want them
to be second granular or something like
that yep I agree okay so in general with
select do we have anything which has an
option of granularity they're all
arguments right right now yeah they're
all arguments how does it work in date
range just date range now that you said
it just inherits the granularity of the
start it does we - for experimentation
purposes there's an undocumented fourth
argument that will let you specify the
granularity because there's some weird
edge cases where your step size may you
know we look at the step size to try and
determine the units but there may be a
better granularity than the fact that
you're adding two days you know four
days and a week maybe you want them to
come back as weeks instead of specific
days or something like that well so what
you're implying is maybe we should have
a date Garrety option that we can supply
to all these things including date
object which might canonicalize itself
to not use that but it could start that
way
is that what you're suggesting and that
way we can use the pattern of third
argument select as the count yeah I mean
it right now I can't think of anything
we're having a date granularity option
would be a problem or a bad thing you
know in date object it's perhaps a
little redundant but we already have a
method for handling redundant
specifications of you know this date
object already has a time zone and I
specify a different time zone and we
convert it from one to the other
yes so well it seems reasonable to me so
then then the next question is is it ok
to have this notion of the as if
Association type concept for that second
argument because what you're effectively
having to do I don't even know how you
could possibly implement this I mean
you've got to go in and look inside
there and you know it's got to be
lexically scoped because you've got to
actually look inside what hache
whatever's were there see what I'm
saying it's been a little while since I
dug into it but we basically we look at
the the named hash functions and then
try and do a quick you know we basically
look at the parameters that each of
those are associated with so we know if
we're looking at hour and minute and we
can ignore the other parameters and and
just the other issue then is whether
it's a string or something else in other
words you've got to know for each of
these is it supposed to be like for
example if I say day name I would kind
of expect that to be a string but it
isn't in fact yeah yeah they're nice to
be able to say okay so let's let's walk
through this again a little bit more so
let's imagine that I said our greater
than six okay so what I would expect to
get back is a bunch of data intervals
right bunch of DEET intervals why not
for today honey that let's say let's say
I said um you know let's say this thing
was this week why doesn't that work why
doesn't that work
that's another bug
that's really weird what happens if I
say last week and you can do current
date take a look at that well okay those
are bugs that's done why that can work
um
but okay the selection there would be I
could say date interval of you know now
- one month - now for example and then
what I would expect to get back here is
the date intervals corresponding to um
you know corresponding to the the after
6:00 a.m. each day right and similarly
then if I were to apply this to a time
series that's a hard time series and I
say that of this result I would expect
to get the time series with pieces
chopped out of it
Koecher does that work time series with
disjoint pieces in the way you simply
don't give the I mean how do you specify
that the time series is missing a
certain number of hours if you have an
explicit missing or what do you do but
you simply not give those I mean no you
can do the time series window right and
then it's cannot just window the pieces
that you want but what I'm saying is
what I've got is a disjoint set of times
over which there is a signal see what
I'm saying you know the weather station
shut itself down between 2:00 a.m. and
6:00 a.m. let's say right and so in here
what I would have is in this way of
setting it up I'm saying I want to
select out of the signal I want to know
what the temperatures were the time when
the weather station was awake okay so
what I want is then to chop out those
times that are between 2:00 a.m. and
6:00 a.m. and then I want to get the
results and the question is how do you
represent that in the if you simply
leave out those entries if it's
interpolating it's going to interpolate
right across that that period when it
was asleep
let's go what I'm saying mm-hmm
so let's see I mean okay so what we're
saying here
all right so provisionally okay so I
don't understand how this relates to
time series did it go should you have
something to say about that particular
issue no because I think you yuge in
this situation you would you would want
to have two methods of interpolation
depending where you are right yes and so
we don't support it at this point okay
so we should think about how to deal
with that but that's a separate thing
here okay so I don't see away okay so
this is reminiscent of the I'm now going
to okay so in a slightly hacky way we
could create an association here that in
other words let's say in the case of
handler function keys handler functions
Keys has an analogous su you know what
I'm saying here what a completely crazy
example well anyway whatever
okay so handler functions keys is being
given
that is very weird what is this doing
you you guys people here know how
handler functions keys works I'm not
familiar with it okay so the way it
works is there are handlers which do
things upon particular events and the
question is what is the argument
structure that is fed to the handlers oh
you know this is right this is right so
the handler here is being given the
evaluation result there are many
possible handler function keys
okay let's submit the functions that
submit the tasks so for example sessions
submit will have many possible handler
function keys okay which means that the
actual handlers that are being used in
um following events can be generated
okay possible keys specified by handler
function keys you see where I'm going
with this so so in a sense what we're
doing is we've got an as if Association
and the question is what keys are going
to be generated for the as if
Association okay yeah um and what we're
saying is what I'm suggesting is there's
an automatic choice of that that's based
on inspecting the actual expression then
principle you could specify the explicit
list of keys so the full form of this
might look like I mean we'd have to give
if it was an argument for example we'd
say infinity here comma and then we'd
say list our and that says go get the
date value for our and return the
Association our arrow date value of blah
kamar our okay what I'm saying
now I'm not sure that even works because
in this case where we're doing
it's hardly as if you can say date value
of this day tenth of all right by the
way we've got a bunch of seashore
background noise which i think is go
Shias fault so you might want to I don't
know are you sitting in the server room
it's right behind my back well I thought
the room was completely closed well who
knows wait a minute it's well must be
the main one on the sixth floor mm-hmm
yes but how does it make noise I don't
understand that I don't know but but
it's it's completely closed isn't it
something you know when you hear it then
it's hard to on here okay so let's see
where were we so I don't think this
works right because what you're doing
here is you're extracting I don't even
know how would you implement this let's
talk about that Nick yeah so for the
date interval case it's a little tricky
I mean basically what we end up doing
with the the basic months when
implementation we have now is that we
look at the implicit interval and we
look at the keys that are needed so in
this case our and we basically generate
an explicit range that we can then good
enough look at this case our greater
than six that's not good enough
right if it's our equals six it's fine
but I think you want this case don't
worry I think the problem here is that
we are mixing the discrete case with the
continuous case and and that's
potentially dangerous well you mean
something which can return an interval I
think we're gonna need that I mean in
other words of course okay so this is a
case where we can do a comparison but
for example days after
Monday how do we deal with that how do
we represent that because we can't say
de name greater than Monday that's kind
of crazy yes but but I think they'd
select should still return a list of
particular dates they may have they may
have different granularities but they
should be all date objects not dating
there was well so you're denying the
possibility of our greater than six men
because we can't represent our greater
than six with a date object because
state orchards only live on these
granularity points that correspond to
you know there were centered unnamed
values like a named hour or something
you can't go 12:30 to 1:30 right it
would have to be a a date object for
12:30 one for one thirty one for you see
I think though that's useful because to
be able to say 1:30 to 2:30 every day
this week but you could do that with
dates select if we allowed a if we
allowed something other than okay
basically the issue is do we allow so
date interval okay if date interval
specifies something which is on
essentially the the granularity of the
granularity point of an hour for
instance if it was two to three actually
I don't know whether how does that work
died out in an hour two o'clock it's not
clear that that represents two to three
is it no no that represents two to three
look I think the functionality that we
can get by by having inequalities as
well as equalities service is very
useful but perhaps they need separate
functions they'd select and they
inter-are select and then you know what
you are going to get back why does it
matter whether you get a granular data
object or a date interval I mean a date
interval is a granular date object that
just doesn't happen to be aligned on the
granularity about you know boundaries
well it's we don't have other functions
solvers that we don't know whether they
are country tour numbers or interval
fund let's come back to my statement
because I'm not sure it's correct is it
the case that the you know granular date
the our wise granular date to p.m. is
the same thing as the data interval from
2 p.m. to 3 p.m. is that the same or is
it not the same I don't see them as the
same thing for me the granular object is
a is a discreet object that has its own
algebra and then the other one is a
continuous set of instance yeah you may
be right
ok so you're proposing the possibility
of a date interval select yes and that
put always return date intervals that
may be even even point wise in the sense
of having the same beginning and end if
necessary well but what's the difference
then the date select could only give you
if you said our greater than so at 6 the
date selected would just fail is that
right or you could do it on our list of
all the hours after 6 something that
it's just a different interpretation
something that we work in the in the
discrete world I'd say I see what you're
saying i suicide no returning all hours
after 6 would make sense there okay yeah
I think that's reasonable um alright so
maybe Nick maybe you could try and
actually implement date select okay
including I mean including this idea
that whatever interval it is so can't
date range date range can't take an
interval like that it can't really I
mean the a lot of the functions that
operate on date ranges right now use a
two or three argument start date and
they and potentially step with the
interval you know we basically smush two
arguments together and date intervals
themselves are intended to be contiguous
so there isn't really a step size
associated with them yep
yeah there's no grand Irish in a date
interval right dateable is just a slab
of time yeah this moment to this moment
it could be infinite past infinite
future or beginning of yesterday to end
of tomorrow there's a discrete starting
and stop point at least are you doing
with the temporal logic business it
depends how much time we want to spend
talking about it we're moving along
josé's been doing a lot of reading about
it and we've gone over Rogers old PhD
thesis and a handful of other things
we're we've got a generally good idea of
the you know the the hook ends to linear
temporal logic and and how they relate
to modal logic but we're still kind of
playing around with how it integrates
into the language in terms of you know
setting up the the various relationships
between this eventually happens this
always happens this happens until this
period etc but let's talk a little bit
about how that relates to this so
effectively we have a collection of new
logical operators called things like
until eventually next and and they take
predicates and potentially a time to
express when well so maybe it's
temporary next temporarily next and
things like this right right and
eventually mm-hm
so you're saying so what will be a thing
that you would say you would say
eventually such-and-such eventually P so
right yes it's it's yes exactly we have
propositions whose truth depends on time
so eventually P is the assertion that at
some time in the future P will be true
is that correct
exactly yep so what would be an example
of a piece of the soul
what would it mean let's say that P will
be true sometime this year how would you
represent that sometime this year so so
well there exists a time okay so this is
a this is a case exists a time this year
when bla bla bla bla bla
yes so so here so sorry a new thing
because we have several of these
operators so basically the fundamental
ones could be said to be until and
eventually so we have one in which we
can express that something is going to
happen until some other things happen so
this is until P comma Q I still pick on
a time yes or until P comma a operator
typically using in in temporal logic
greet relates the truth of two different
proposition so it's P comma Q and this
is something that holds now so the time
is now
so we know now that P will hold until Q
holds and then we don't care whether P
holds or not this is sort of things that
so what's the relationship with actual
times the temporal logic and actual
times so until you know this holds until
well Q could be given a time itself Q
could be something that we know that
will start happening only at a given
time
basically true when we could we could
represent that statement by having the
date there and then we have that date
objects are statements it's like a
deltas in time something that happens at
there it's it's true at the time that
they represent I see so it's effectively
a delta function so so in a sense that
is saying you know true at or true
during write to drawing some time which
might be a granular time right okay and
this will be like a true until so is
true until Q is true right so true until
is an assertion yeah it's like so while
I mean so while if I say because I can
imagine something where you're actually
running a process and you're saying you
know I mean this is a symbolic version
of true until yes yes but what I'm
saying is that the general case is
having two propositions they're having
that time it's a particular case of lat
yeah okay fair enough okay
so let's go back by the way as wsh on
the live stream is asking does the date
interval from future to past make sense
I assume that's than now one table I
mean I assume like it's if I say
something like the interval from 2 to
minus 2 like this what is that now is
that how do I say what is the if I say
region measure of that well interval
sorts oh I see it just sorted right
there mm-hmm it's not clear that we want
that for time intervals I wouldn't have
thought we'd
mm-hmm okay yeah I mean interval is not
a directed interval in the case of the
number line
should it be for a date interval not
clear mm-hmm yeah I think it's I think
you should preserve orientation because
orientation for us is going to be very
important yeah
okay let's let's loop back here so we've
got a possible idea for date selection
data interval select and also date
interval itself now let's go loop back
to the original discussion Wow it looks
a lot of it's a lot of random times
there um which is the time object okay
so time object is an example then what
the heck is time object wants to be a
generic time within so in other words if
I say that time object and I add a day
to that time object what enough happens
like this time object here okay is in my
time zone and that time object is that
okay great now what happens so if I say
time object of now okay okay all right
so if I were to say add a day to this
time object okay so that time object
plus um one day because we
the head it basically remains unchanged
it does actually you know if you add
half of a day or something to it it will
change the offset but if you add
anything in in multiple of 24 hours it
will not okay now why is that correct
what happens if there's a if the time if
the daylight savings time changes well
in this particular case the time donuts
use ding since its selecting it from the
system and it's just in numeric offset
the daylight savings doesn't get
accounted for in that way but GMT right
yeah man Jim t minus 4 which is an
explicit time zone relative to GMT yeah
versus if it was using your dollar time
zone entity that's probably America /
New York which is Eastern Standard Time
with why doesn't just give something in
Eastern Time I mean why is it giving it
as GMT - whatever instead of printing it
as est or whatever it is right now we're
doing that because dollar time zone has
been a real value since version 2 and we
introduced timezone entity and support
for timezone entities in version 10 I
believe and we want to transition to
using you know modern time zones but we
didn't want to switch over it the second
that we added it so we have for this
yeah I mean I think the discussion was
going to be you know the the next major
version would be the earliest where we
want to talk about it because the next
major version is almost upon us
mm-hmm yeah I mean I think it makes
sense to shift to these time zones there
you know a modern notion of what a time
zone is and we have good coverage yeah I
know 30 years ago we didn't have the
same opportunity but ok so question um
that's a separate discussion ok but so
what you're claiming is that this time
object I can perfectly well add once it
has a time zone it's a little bit
funkier to add a day yeah I mean there's
the central dogma of time
object has been that it doesn't care
what any given day is unless you give it
to a function that needs to another day
if you say date list of a time object it
needs to know what the first three
elements are and so it will say okay I
assume you're talking about today
because I don't have any better
information okay fine so this should do
the same thing if you add something it
is going to need to know that right it's
gonna need to know that in order to add
a day to a time object it's gonna need
to know which day you're talking about
and it will have to assume I would think
they talking about today actually adding
a day it's not obvious what it should do
it's really not obvious cuz it could be
that you want to add the granular day as
opposed to adding 24 hours okay let's
come back to this question about um okay
this this question about a generic time
okay how does that relate to what we
were talking about before I think it's
related in terms of you know we don't we
don't have a generic date object that
floats around where you can say you know
this is the fourth day of an a month or
the fourth day of April but it doesn't
matter what the year is time objects is
sort of existed in this weird headless
form where you can say this is a time
object we know it rotates around on a
24-hour clock you can give it a specific
time zone but if you try and instantiate
it to any given moment it just has to
assume you're talking about it today and
I think you know since time object
hasn't propagated throughout the system
extensively you know we've used it in
places where it's applicable but it's
kind of more of a narrow construct than
data object is the the general question
and sort of if we want to update it to
include granularity is do we want to
think about time object being just 24
hours on a clock that always tries to
reduce to a specific mo
and time is it generally assumed not to
have a time dough unless you say it
needs to have a time zone or are we
thinking of it as a specific version of
this generic date concept and if that's
the case should we explore that in more
detail rather than say time objectivity
time zone less thing mm-hmm
unless you know I think that would be a
much better use of this as to have it be
time zone this and it only locks into a
time zone if you're doing an operation
that requires you know anchoring to a
time zone just like it only locks into a
day if you you know a specific date if
you it's like yeah I mean we could get
ridiculously ornate so for example um it
let's see so the question is I mean what
okay to be very ornate I mean like for
example I don't think we're accounting
for the change in the length of the day
right with seconds are we have we
there's no there's no formal notion in
the language of how leap seconds are
handled the variations in time system or
time schemes
you know UTC versus you TZ 0 versus T ia
etc that's something that we're looking
at as part of the Astronomy work that
Jose has been doing because we need that
granular control but in general the
language basically assumed so that it
doesn't need to keep track of leap
seconds it just looks at what your
system clock is and assumes that goes
bad although the time difference between
now and lost January 1st does depend on
leap seconds if you care about the you
know it down to the level of seconds
right
yes that will have to be a new option
time system that specifies whether you
care or not right okay that's gonna get
very ornate I mean by the time we're
dealing with changes in the length of
the day and it's very ornate um okay so
again with time object the question is
should there be a time zone in the time
object gosh I can see I think you know
are sort of easy path is to say the
default is to have none but you can
specify one if you really want to yeah
okay what if time zone none mean so the
way we handle so I think a quarter of
the way down the page there there's an
example of time object with time zone
goes to none no but that basically means
is you yeah so if you send that to me it
will still be you know three seconds
past oh that's something we added
relatively recently I guess you're
probably in version 11 three okay so so
that this is coming in the new version
yeah and so the idea is that you know
normally in a data object when you
create it the time zones instantiated
when you create it with time zone goes
to none we don't instantiate it unless
you do something that says I need to
know the specific moment in time and at
which point it'll assume your dollar
time zone but the notion here is you
create that time object you put it in a
cloud object I read it it's the same
time it still says there's no time zone
even if we're in different time zones
right you know on the live stream flip
Philips is making an interesting point
that scenarios like temporal data you
know when you measure EEG or something
you really don't care you care that this
happened one hour and six minutes from
the beginning of your recording you
don't well you might care actually it
might matter you know what was the
circadian rhythm point for the for the
for the purpose and whose EEG was being
measured
but in generically you don't think you
care
just care about in a you know a start
time relative time yeah and there's a
similar relationship with audio
processing which we've looked at with
Roger a little bit in terms of my my
objects
yeah and how you know how time objects
relate to things like durations where it
what is the what is our thinking about
so this is okay so this is a time zone
on time object and so if I say that plus
seven plus 72 hours okay now what's
gonna happen here
oh gosh this is a version that doesn't
um um this this version that were I
can't connect to the cloud yet okay well
in case what's gonna happen here is it
gonna mod you know mod 24 hours yeah it
will basically mod 24 hours in the
resulting object okay um I think this is
correct because time object is not a
duration it's just the time of the day
when you don't care about the actual
date okay but so let's talk about flips
version of time relative to the
beginning of your experiment how do we
deal with that because as you say in the
audio case I mean we have exactly that
situation right I mean if I go ahead and
and capture some audio here hello there
okay I'm gonna have audio where I could
want to do so how do you so anybody here
now how do i I slice off if I say audio
window is that right what do I do to get
a piece of that audio audio sample you
know so much for that
okay audio trim alright so I could I
could for example trim the audio to a
particular okay so that's the first T
seconds etcetera etcetera etcetera okay
so this is the case
from start time T so that is a quantity
relative to the start well that's not so
bad actually I mean if I say audio trim
of the audio from um
[Music]
it's some um you know from a certain
quantity or in other words okay so one
question would be does the audio know
the absolute time in other words this
audio was recorded from the security you
know microphone or whatever at you know
322 p.m. or something it doesn't know
that does it does anybody know how that
works
I answer but in principle I don't know
why it should not I mean why it should
have to record that no I understand it
wouldn't generically wouldn't record
that the question is if you wanted to
record that can you record the absolute
you know physical time at which an audio
recording is made later for example it
could be metadata but but but then the
selection I mean right now with our time
series right okay so there's a question
for Gosha here okay so in our time
series is it the case that the times are
always absolute or can you have purely
relative times so no the times time
sorry the moments in time they exist
well but no but if I say all I care
about is how long since the beginning of
the time series this particular value is
occurring at I don't care it's three
minutes and two 22 seconds after the
beginning of the time series I couldn't
care less whether that's 4:00 in the
morning or 6:00 in the evening or this
year or last year right I mean so you
can put an integer in the reel so
integers is the timestamps
so in this situation when you recorded
audio it goes from zero seconds to zero
you know zero two seconds okay so then
what would happen if I had that okay so
there are a couple of different cases
then so let's imagine here
I've got my time's my you know my my
thing here I'll even use the
interpolated one just to be nice in % 38
right I'm going to take it and I'm gonna
say % 38 and then I'm going to say two
point five days no because that's just a
duration
yeah but that's no but that's not
because the other interpretation of that
is since the values that you would okay
look if you were going to give this if
you were gonna give a time series where
it says um you know it says zero and the
value is six and then it says one day
and the value is 7 right two days and
the value is 18 right that should be a
valid time series is it no why not
because you'll at this point you're
mixing the the quantities with welder
zero you know which is the integer well
I'm sorry but that's zero days what what
zero day is gonna turn into it stays
alright so that's a valid time series
nope what did I do wrong because that at
this point this is also something that
I'm looking into we do not accept
quantities on the timestamps I think we
should we shouldn't I agree with you and
this is in in the you know in the to do
list okay all right but let's assume we
do that right so then I claim the
consistent thing to do here is that that
means give me the value two point five
days after the beginning of this time
series right well if you had two
started at two seconds then it would be
0.5 seconds after the beginning where if
the value if the value of the first time
stamp was 2 seconds and then I say 2.5
seconds there no I think these things
should always be absolutely if you give
days with some numbers then when you
input the value it means the same thing
like we do with Lakes no but wait a
second so what we're saying here is in
okay so there's an ambiguity in the case
where a time series has absolute x in it
right and then I say show me two point
five days now that kind of means two
point five days since the beginning of
the time series look one of the things
and actually flip is pointing this out
on the live stream
oh it says it's flips birthday today
happy birthday since we're talking about
x right the question is how many leap
seconds has flipped accumulated in his
life so far um they in a case the the
the question is whether whether T equals
zero whether there is a representation
some symbolic representation for the you
know the beginning of the epoch so to
speak because right now we have now and
now represents in physical time so to
speak well I'm confused I mean in
astronomy this issue comes up all the
time right relative to the current epoch
relative to whatever else it is yes
always assume that both the inputs in
the first argument of time series and
then the input you if I refer to the
same D book yeah okay in that sense of
epoch but what I'm
saying is if your time series is a
recording of the motion of your snail
starting from T equals zero for the next
18 minutes or something right yeah then
the issue is and and the way that that
specified is with something very much
like this right the snail the snail
recording device is every five seconds
it gives the snail position and the
first element there in each case is five
seconds 10 seconds 15 seconds and so on
then the question is if I want to get
there it's perfectly reasonable for me
to say where is the snail after 18
seconds yes but the question is if I
record it instead the absolute time the
snail started its journey at 4 p.m. and
continued wandering around until 4:15
and now I want to say give me the
position of the snail 5 minutes after
the start of the time series how do I do
that
go show how would I do that for the time
series swindell do you have to use the
time of the beginning plus 5 minutes
mmm that's right which means that you
have an ugly thing where you're saying
the how would he even do that I mean if
I have the time series there is no
symbolic representation of you know I
mean in other words I could say
something like beginning plus 5 minutes
we have the first time yes all first
date first time it gives you the first
time of the all the time series okay so
if I take that time series and I say
first time no property so you if it's
over time serious its yeah first time I
thought we had but duration okay so
first time gives what the heck is s if
you want to date do the Thursday this is
absolute time that's horrifying the date
that it's the first date
okay that's horrifying we did it created
this operating in the absolute time
before the date
chat was introduced so that's why that
is well I think it should be largely
deprecated that particular thing right
is to function somehow duration also
works it's the difference between the
first and asanas okay fine
but so what what doesn't work is
something like this because otherwise
this is a pretty ugly thing you've got
to repeat that time series you've got to
say that whole time series okay there
you know what you've got to say is this
thing of let's say I want to find out
the weather you know okay plus you know
four point five days you know that's
getting in the pretty ugly category and
it's good it works would it be accepted
I want to have a string class no buying
no absolutely not no string we're not
gonna add strings that's a that's a
slippery slope that we're we're gonna
yeah but I think it would be acceptable
possibly I don't know you know is it
acceptable and this relates again to the
temporal logic business it's like
beginning plus four point five days is
that a meaningful time we're beginning
is a symbolic thing well some of the
references I Fred use the word start as
a symbolic as a symbolic thing that is
in there in the syntax like like we have
to unfold they start yeah I think the
better be called beginning rather than
start because start has too many other
meanings of verb form and so on but in
any case doesn't really matter but but
or time origin or some such other thing
mm-hmm
okay so if there was a thing called
beginning I guess there's also ending
then and those are symbolic things oh
that's a weird situation right because
how would that relate to the now we have
the first stage and then within this
property maybe about adding quantity so
then you call it once
sorry fill it again
if instead of beginning you know we can
think about having the first date plus
this quantity of five minutes that we
could maybe parse know this but we're
not gonna do strings and we're not gonna
do arithmetic with strings it's a it's
horrifying um yeah so so if flipper is
suggesting you know that there's an
option called epoch the word epoch is
such a confusing word I have to say but
but one can have a better version of
that where what that means is how what
the time is relative to so the
alternative here would be something like
this where in the meaning of the word
epoch which I don't you know it would be
something like that which means this
time so it's like a time zone an epoch
then becomes a bit like a time zone yeah
book sounds much bigger by epoch is the
wrong name okay so let's say this is
time origin or something right it's I'm
not sure that's right either but but
that would be the way of determining see
I don't think that's right I mean I
think it would better to have or
alternatively yes another alternative
would be relative time blah
we think about that so where else would
that be used let's imagine there was a
notion of relative time I mean I guess
there was the example you gave earlier
in the stream where air temperature data
of here and three weeks means three
weeks relative to today which must go
backwards in time
well that's an a-minus relative time
yeah
it's implicitly moving backwards because
the function knows that it can't move
forward in time yeah it's a little bit
cruddy but but the question is what
would this so in the time series there
are two things again okay so let's just
understand in the time series there's
either you know input for the time
series is either absolute times and I
don't mean absolute times in our sense
of crazy integers and things but I mean
it means physical time so to speak okay
right all the input is purely relative
times right and then again the query in
can either be you know in in absolute
times or relative times but relativist
times are durations they are quantities
and so we could interpret quantities in
the first case as refer to the beginning
but in the second case it couldn't be
they have to be referred to the input
yeah I know but that's the problem no
you see the problem is okay so look this
is the problem there actually isn't
relative times this isn't correct
this is this is merely okay so there's
actually three different cases there's
the input absolute times as the input
quantities or time specified times but
not dates okay which looks like
quantities right it's gonna say it's
going to say
one day two days three days okay you
know the problem is this isn't relative
times this is just quantities because it
doesn't necessarily start at zero so the
problem is here what does it mean when
you ask for day 1.5 if I'd started with
you know day 1 here and I had gone to
day 3 and now I asked for day 1.5 what
do I want see what I'm saying to me
because if we removed the days and we
had only integers it will go simply
interpolate between 1 & 2 it should do
this okay because we also want the
possibility of relative to the beginning
of the of the time series which is this
construct relative time or something I
would prefer the beginning plus but okay
fine okay so I think beginning plus is
interesting and reasonable but where
else would we use that someone on the
live stream is talking about relativity
we can we have multiple people on this
call who understand that business quite
well but we are we are not going to
solve the relativistic problem here
we're going to solve part of that
problem when we do astronomical times
right we have to do some of that is that
true I say yes indeed the UM no flip is
suggesting time object versus timing
object yeah I don't know I mean that's a
possibility is something like a relative
time object I don't think that's right
either you know I think what quantities
should cover that quite well all the
cases it's just that if we want to refer
quantity with respect to some beginning
or or the beginning we need a way to
specify the beginning right but what
else
we'll be used the beginning for other
than in time series where else will be
used beginning well in in temporal logic
for a process that has a clear beginning
could be used how well okay what is the
value okay so beginning what's a little
weird is you know that first date thing
it's some you know that's an extractor
that takes the time series and gives you
know and gives a specific first date
first time whatever in the time series
okay this is an implicit representation
of that and there's something a little
odd about having both of those flapping
around in other words beginning does
resolve okay so there's a calculus of
times that are relative to the beginning
that could be its own so for example we
might say beginning plus five minutes
and then we might go you know add three
days to that and then we know how to do
that it's just beginning plus three days
plus five minutes and so on right
mmm-hmm if we had a second beginning
there and we said beginning - beginning
what does it mean in other words it's
like it's like degrees centigrade or
something there's a you know beginning
okay so look like for example beginning
- beginning what is it is it zero no I
think this will be symbolic it will give
zero we end up with a quantity and we
complain because we don't know how to
refer that quantity or perhaps we assume
that object when were to date whether I
mean somewhere okay
resolving this by saying the beginning
is at this physical time so to speak
beginning in a time series that contains
that objects will be implicitly a date
object but in a time series that
contains
quantities it will be implicitly the
first quantity you know okay but so
where else could this occur I mean so
for example the sub value construct is
not used in is it used in for example
date interval you know a date interval
in a sense has I mean I don't think this
is particularly correct syntax but
something like day 10th of all blah blah
blah you know for example I thinking
that Michael and right now once a deer
trajectory we are working on an idea
trajectory so we are going to have the
same from their beginning of this very
interesting right
so the Geo trajectory could be an
absolute time the space station went
over at precisely this time or it could
be when I start driving to Timbuktu or
whatever I you know 300 hours into the
drive I'm at this place
right yeah that's interesting so the geo
trajectory would have I see so so in the
case of the Geo trajectory one would be
able to select how would one select part
of the geo trajectory you have to have
its own function to do that oh can that
be selected with for example date select
for example I haven't thought about that
yet
hmm so the idea was to have some sort of
part spec like language in and if we
whatever we do for for yes for the lists
of dates or some date span something
that should be eaten by just reject Li
yeah so but reject fundamentally is like
a time series except that and what's the
difference between a time series where
the values are geo points and a geo
trajectory well the secretary knows how
to handle the G or details of things and
will be able to compute the velocity
from when you are moving a things does
so somehow it knows that it represents
something moving in curved space around
the earth
yes it's a lot of information that
internally I mean like for example the
time series functionality should
presumably work on geo trajectories yes
like why not time series window should
be able to work on a geo trajectory
their haps I mean we would have to
generalize all these linear things to
the curve case and I'm not sure
you mean interpolations interpolations
and and computations to them you can add
two time serious well no you can't add
to clear trajectories that's crazy
exactly right that's a good point
but you could take the difference
between two geo trajectories imagine
okay
imagine you have two paths you know the
path whatever it is the less taken
whatever that you know imagine you have
your tracking wolves or something and
they the pack all starts together and
then they diverge and you want to know
you have geo trajectories for each wolf
right yes you could imagine subtracting
two geo trajectories and what would you
expect to get you get a vector field
basically that shows the difference
between the wolf positions it's but it's
not exactly that the in the same way
that do we cannot subtract to your
positions we cannot subtract but we can
compute for example the geo displacement
between both and that will return
perhaps a time series of jelly's
placements or something like that yeah
okay that makes sense because the cheer
displacement value right then it has
turned itself into a pure time series
yes I think so but it cannot be just
abstraction because the geo positions do
not form a vector field fair enough okay
so then what is the relationship so then
geo trajectory the time aspects of a geo
trajectory are perfectly you know number
line e right it's just the Geo values or
not you know are not simple like that
exactly the values are do positions
effectively so they have to follow the
algebra of position which is more
complicated
it's not yet a generalization so I mean
basically your point here is this is
living okay but in geo trajectory in
space and XYZ coordinates is Euclidean I
mean in XYZ coordinates you can do the
subtraction right you can yes you would
have to work with vectors from the
center of the earth yes but in principle
with your trajectory we are not
committing to any particular kind of
coordinate system we will be able to
query and say give me in that lawn or in
one or the other one just just looking
ahead for a second and I really have to
go because I'm really late for something
else when we have a stroke positions is
this going to work the same way
well if we have some sort of all of it
and we describe an orbit that's
something that depends on time we will
need something similar yes although that
has yet more horrifying stuff like an
orbit is periodic typically yes and a
trajectory could be periodic if I mean
we could have the satellite following a
Giotto sector II yes have we even
thought even for a moment about the
relativistic stuff for the Astro
position business I have thought a bit
and it's also important for the time
systems because there are there are time
clocks that there are time systems that
take into account the fact that you are
in the Sun or on the earth and the
relativity is different
give me a gravitational redshift reasons
exactly yes so this is all measured and
there are parameters to how you move
from one time system to the other one
but just just jumping ahead for one
second and then we really should wrap
this up I mean so so if you have an
asteroid trajectory for example like
yeah clearly there are relativistic
things going on there because the
asteroid trajectory well I don't even
know look if you have an astral position
on Mars for example right with a twenty
minute
propagation delay
what the heck is that so there's I see
there's a time system how does that work
the important thing here is
distinguishing the description of what
is happening right now in some time
coordinate system with what you see if
you look at it then when you see is when
you have to take into account that there
is a shift in time between one and thing
at the other so things can be moved so
we will have to be saying something like
what do you see from the earth at that
time and then we will have to trace back
in time where things were and take into
account those things but so the actual I
mean to be sort of technical about it I
mean there's a bunch of space like hyper
surfaces that define the moments of time
right and those things are spaced like
in the sense that they are not you know
there's no you can't you can't actually
you know you can't get from one to the
other that they're just they're just
some kind of foliation of space-time and
that's that's that is the tick's of your
clock you say based on that different
from what you actually different from
the observation of where you know the
planet is or whatever else exactly yes
so it's like when we were computing
eclipses we had to take into account the
fact that the light takes one second to
go from the moon to the earth and so
things will be shifted to one second if
you don't taking that into account
social activity here means basically
finite the speed of light yes that's the
first approximation then in a second
approximation things get moved by by
Lorentz factors and things like that but
that's a smaller effect okay so your
point is you can perfectly well define
an asteroid trajectory with respect to
this time coordinate system that's
defined by this series of space like
hyper surfaces which is in a sense not
observable but nevertheless can be
specified like that exactly exactly so
do you need to know whether you are
referring to the one based on the solar
system body center or the one based on
the center of the earth or the one Bay
on some other galactic thing to
coordinate changes but once you have
defined a coordinate system that covers
everything as much as relativity allows
then then what was that as much as
relatively allows what because because
for example we're on the rotating earth
you cannot define something that covers
completely Hollow Earth because we are
in a non-inertial systems and things of
that so there are there are issues that
force you to have this coordinate
systems to have a maximum size what I
mean wait a minute there are coordinate
why does the I mean you know when you
have black holes and things and you have
all kinds of weird coordinate chart
stuff but why do you have that for just
a pure rotating earth yes when do you
have rotating effects
you cannot have global coordinate
systems that cover and global
transistors based on light rays and
things like that this is them so-called
sonic effect yeah okay I didn't think
that okay so we're going to run into
that well the coordinate systems defined
of own based on various planets and
things they have a size that it's the
size that they make sense well are you
saying
I mean look clearly a code I see I see I
see here's a simple way to understand
that if you have the XYZ coordinate
system going out from the center of the
earth at some point is you go far enough
out radially from the earth your
rotation speed will be larger than the
speed of light for example yeah right so
it gets completely crazy at that point
right I mean while you're in low-earth
orbit it's far far away from that but if
you would go out you know I don't really
know how far but but you know a rigid
coordinate system maybe even out to the
edge of the solar system might start to
give you trouble is that the origin of
this effect so you can't continue the
coordinate system outward because it you
end up with
some kind of lots of necessary
relativistic effects right and and in
fact the coordinate systems that are
used based on the Sun for example are
non rotating because they are aligned
with some distant object which is
supposed to be known as I understand to
avoid this type of effect how subtle
okay all right
okay well we have degenerated into into
something kind of complicated here all
right well good thanks okay so this I
think we've made some good progress here
and we need to pick this up again but
why don't we work through what we
already figured out here mm-hmm
and thanks to everybody on the
livestream we we we I won't say we fell
down a black hole at the end because
we're not even considering those kinds
of effects but anyway got close to that
all right thanks all see you later